We set this up to be as natural as possible.
We used historical data on
the types of trees that would be damaged by
120 mile an hour winds.
We then pulled those trees over using a cable and a winch and then we've been following this for the last 30 years.
This LTER research
is just
the bread and butter, the basic fabric of
the Harvard forest. It was established to be a
laboratory and classroom
where the faculty, the students, all the research scientists really lived spent their lives and so they could
understand
nature and the way people interact with nature firsthand all through the year.
Most important result out of this is that although the forest
look destroyed it actually is
functioning as a perfectly intact ecosystem and what it shows is the ability of nature to cope, the resilience and
persistence of a forest and so it's oftentimes absolutely best to leave nature alone
to recover on its own.